swell designer asks I'm curious to know
what your thoughts are on tech
consumption by young children this is an
interesting one because I've done a lot
of lucky serendipitous piggybacking on
today's questions because I just went
into that and you know kids are all up
in this right now and I think it's
evolution I mean if you were to ask the
person that was like me during the
caveman days on his or her show what you
think about humans that look like us
today all of you cavemen and women be
like no terrible but we've evolved and I
think that children are growing up with
technology we are definitely going into
that futuristic world and I think it's
great I think that they're going to be
different versions of us but that's not
bad I'm not the dad that's it'd be like
get outside and play of course I want
them to be healthy but don't forget our
kids are eating a hell of a lot better
than any of us all our Big Macs everyday
are held a lot different than kale chips
that we're all growing up with now and
so there's trade-offs you know maybe not
to mention more people work out now so
you know I think the more gonna be more
informational to me less information
smart because it's a commodity because
anything you want to know is here and I
think they're just gonna be different
characters and so I'm super excited
about it I think it's a I think it's a
phenomenal I love the children growing
up totally different I'm curious and ER
thinking everything swipes there's some
downsides like everything else I'm
worried about them being as active but
you can if you're a good parent you can
do whatever you want but I'm not
restricting hours of a second screen or
third screen for my children because I
think it's actually prepping them for
the world it's actually gonna exist
straight up it's kind of almost like
alcohol right like kids like wanna drink
because in America we don't let them
drink and so like you know the kids
they're going to be restricted to one
hour a day or gonna overvalue this and
so I'm just I'm very fascinated by it
and I'm a very go with the flow kind of
character and I'll also adjust to the
reality of how my kids adapt to it